do begin with an officer-involved
shooting in the north part of the valley
this happened earlier this morning
near the corner of nellis and las vegas
boulevard our bianca holman is there
live with the very latest and bianca
what can you tell us
alex this is a very dynamic situation
you can see
officers are still here this area is
still blocked off
several officers and armored vehicles
were here and so this is what we know
so far this was officer involved
shooting number
11 for the year they got a report of a
man attempting to light
trees and cars on fire when police made
contact with him he showed up
he showed a gun and the suspect ran away
the man ran into a mobile home park it
was the storyville mobile home park here
a few people were inside one of the
mobile homes that he ran into
they were able to get out but then the
man took a woman hostage
the swat they were able to come to the
scene they were able to get inside
they actually shot the suspect he died
on scene and the woman was able to make
it out
now body camera footage and more details
about what happened this morning will be
released
in the next 72 hours reporting live from
near nellis in las vegas boulevard
bianca holman
8 news now